[Applaudissements]
le temps où ils soient en concurrence
sur le jt on est d'accord et on les a
positionnés je pensais pas un hasard
entre les ja côté de la presse 2 cela
donc je pense que ça sent le gaz entre
on peut pas travailler dopage et il est
tout fier de savoir s'il était en
concurrence bien mais seule une intro le
là pour toi ça va très très bien merci
c'est très élégant eu de vraiment bravo
bravo je pense que effectivement moi je
suis fan de toi en tout cas je trouve
que tu es un amant cave
il assure de l'émission salut les
copains
e
ça fait plaisir
la côté est folle à traiter jambières il
a pris sa tête de beau gosse mais grave
au tapis alors continuer ça lui a jamais
fait des grands plans sont jean michel
maire ça fait du bien je trouve qu'il
fait un truc incroyable c'est qu'il est
digne en toute circonstance six rondes
dans les rues sur une situation
totalement improbable est toujours là
dink pardon j'ai qu'est-ce que je te
dire je m'excuse et ben je mixe membres
se voient et et je trouve ça incroyable
sur tombe toujours sur tes pieds et je
trouve que tu es si belle avant émission
merci ouais ça fait vers 6,4 est belle
avait à oui ah oui et ça c'est quand
elle attendait le bus sata mais
jean-michel on s'en fout vraiment
déboires idées à fond il faut absolument
bossé et j'ai jamais vous bossez autant
une chronique
on va voir notre photo non mais c'est
plutôt de sexe vous le sous préfet
depuis combien d'années le calendrier je
crois que c'est le treizième 13e
calendrier et on les a tous vous les
avez tous eu jean-michel j'en ai 11 à
vous il va donc de la probable